and the only talk today uh in this uh
question
is
by ninabal
from georgia tech we'll be talking about
this introduction
all right thank you thomas so
this talk is about distributing machine
learning and in particular i will be
talking about a theoretical model that
we have been developing for reasoning
about
key issues and resources
appearing when we want to do
supervised learning in distributed
settings
okay and since this is a little bit of a
broader audience i will uh in terms of
the structure of my talk i'll start by
giving a very quick high level overview
about uh
the usual way to analyze supervised
learning in the classic centralized
setting and then i will present our
results
okay so as probably everyone here knows
supervising machine learning is one of
the most well studied or understood
topics in machine learning so in the
setting the learning algorithm would use
labeled examples for instance
email
email messages labeled as spam or not
spam if our goal is to do spam detection
okay and for resetting there are two
very nice
general and closely related models
in particular the statistical learning
theory framework of nic
and pac model of valiant
and in these models we assume that there
exists some underlying probability
distribution over the space of unlabeled
examples for instance over the space of
uh unlabeled email messages
and then in the training phase uh the
learning algorithm first gets to see
in the training phase we first get to
see a random sample
from this distribution this sample is
then labeled by an expert for instance
spam or not spam for the spam detection
problem
and this set of labeled examples is an
input is given as an input to a learning
algorithm
and when the algorithm does some
computation over the sample
and output hypothesis function that is
then used to classify
new examples for instance new email
messages
so for instance for the spam detection
problem if the algorithm represents each
message
by certain features that for instance
represent counts uh of certain keywords
appearing in the message or not when
visual plus plays each
each email message as a point in rn with
what we call the instance space and then
the algorithm might find a hypothesis a
classifier over instant space that could
be say for instance a linear classifier
and this is what classic algorithms like
perceptron or sdm would do
okay so formally
in these models
in the training phase the algorithm
first gets to see
a set of labeled examples for instance
label emails we assume that these
examples are drawn iid from some fixed
but unknown distribution over the
instant space
and we assume that they're also labeled
according to some fixed but unknown
target function
okay and the goal of the algorithm is to
do some optimization over the given
sample in order to find the hypothesis
and this hypothesis to have good uh
small error with respect to the
underlying distribution and in
particular uh the notion of error that
i'm gonna consider for my talk is a
classic uh
zero one error or classification error
loss which is defined as the error rate
of a given hypothesis h is the
probability that our hypothesis h
predicts differently from the target
function on an example drawn at random
from the underlying source
okay now the hypothesis h that we find
comes from some hypothesis space for
instance the class of linear separators
and the case or the target function
itself belongs to the class is called
the realizable case or the noise-free
setting and at the other extreme the
case remain no assumption
is called diagnostic case
okay
so this is a classic formalism and now
in this model
in this models
two the two main aspects that we
typically care about are the following
so the first aspect is
the computational complexity question or
the algorithm design question how can we
automatically generate rules that dwell
over the training sample but well over
the observed data okay and this is has
been
well studied and a lot a number of very
uh interesting algorithms have been
developed right so this is one uh one
important question the algorithm design
question another equally important
question in this models uh
is
the confidence bounds or sample
complexity or generalization guarantees
question
uh quantifying how many examples we need
to see
in order to be confident that the
hypothesis that does all over the
training sample will also dwell in the
future okay and this is super well
understood in this classic framework uh
in this classic setting
so for instance i have on my slides a
classic uh sample complexity stem and
that says
that if the class of functions we are
using has small vc dimension final vc
dimension so for instance the class of
linear separators in rd has this
dimension d so if the class of functions
we are using has
a small vc dimension uh stability
dimension d then uh v over epsilon times
slogan of epsilon examples are
sufficient
uh in order to be
subverted hyper in order to be confident
but with high probability all the
hypotheses that have empirical error
rate zero will have true error rate at
most epsilon
so in other words uh what this statement
is saying is but these many labeled
examples are sufficient in order to make
sure that the bad hypothesis so a
hypothesis is a true error rate at least
epsilon
uh we're not going to fool us because
the hypothesis will be going to be
inconsistent with the data
okay so this is a statement for the
realizable case we can get similar
results uh in diagnostic case in noisy
situations and we can and there is we
can get in fact even more refined bound
and there is a lot of very beautiful
work you know that
provides even
tighter bounds based on more refined uh
notions of complexity rather market
complexity and so on so this is super
well understood
now
uh so this uh right we set these
questions in the classic setting the
algorithm design question simple
complexity question are super understood
okay now
as we have seen
profabi's workshop
many modern machine learning problems
involve massive amounts of data that is
distributed across multiple locations
okay and in such settings
is it it is often the case that you
would like to
do learning
over the union of these data sets and
moreover we want to do this with as
little communication and as few rounds
of communication as possible
right so for instance um we might have
different hospitals with different
distributions of patients and our goal
might be to learn a predictor to say
classify a common misdiagnosis
okay or as a different example we might
have various research groups that have
collected huge amounts of data says
genomic sequence data and our goal is to
do learning over the union of all these
data sets again without too much
communication
okay so
in these examples in such settings the
data is inherently distributed across
multiple locations
and uh each player each holder has only
a piece of the overall data pi and so
clearly uh in order to learn well over
the combined distribution the players
must communicate
okay so basically these settings bring
to the forefront uh very important
communication complexity questions all
right so in the settings you have to
understand the question of how much
communication is needed uh in order to
learn well so in addition to the two
classic aspects that i talked about
sample complexity and computational
complexity these settings bring to the
forefront this communication complexity
question
and they also emphasize other aspects
like privacy incentives and so on
okay so this is precisely the setting
that we study in this work
and
formally
our model is as follows
so we assume that we have k
entities i'm also going to call them
players
as usual we have an instant space like
crn and we assume that each player i has
distribution di over the instant space
and the player can sample points from
the distribution the eye
and
and these examples are then labeled
according to some fixed but non-target
function
and in the setting our goal is to find
the hypothesis h that has small error
rate over the mixture of these
distributions d1 into decay
okay so this is our goal
now as typical again i'm going to fix a
class a a
c a finite vc dimension d i'm going to
call by d as an example you can think
about the classic as being the class of
linear separators and for while i talk
i'm going to focus on the case when k
the number of players is the number of
entities is much smaller than d this
dimension of the concept class
okay and again uh uh
and clearly right in the settings the
players must have to communicate in
order to do well over the joint mixture
and they can do so by sending bits
examples hypotheses and so on
and in particular in this setting
our goal
here is to design learning algorithms
but try to minimize the amount of
communication needed to learn well
and
the two
aspects that we focus on the two
important parameters that we focus on
are the total amount of communication
which can be given by bits examples
hypotheses and also the number of rounds
of communication also known as the
latency
okay and right because i'm
i'm partly theoretical computer
scientist i wanted to also make sure
that
in cases where we can learn the
underlying class of functions by using
efficient polynomial time algorithms i
also wanted to have polynomial time
algorithms investing as well
okay so
here here is actually an interesting
example to better understand the setup
okay so a simple interesting example so
let's assume that you have two players
and that one of them has the positive
examples and the other one has the
negative examples
and so in this case the question is how
much
communication do we need to learn well
over the combined data so know that we
want to dwell over the combined data not
we don't
not only to get the hypothesis hi it
does all over the distribution di
because this problem will be trivial in
this example
okay
so this is our model and
in this model we provide a number of
general results
generic results on the amount of
communication
the upper lower bounds on the amount of
ah all right so this is an overview of
our results
uh let me uh start by talking about uh
two simple bass lines
uh here is a simplest bass line so
the first bass line is each player draws
one over k times d over epsilon of
epsilon examples and sends them to
player one with and player one does the
learning so in other words he finds a
consistent hypothesis
now note that in this case the total
number of examples that get to player 1
is d over epsilon times logan over
epsilon so in this example so really iid
from the underlying mixture then based
on the sample complex system that i had
earlier we would get good generalization
guarantees
now the samples is not quite iid in
particular because on each distribution
the height we have the exact same number
of examples however one can show that
the usual double sample argument for the
vc dimension theorem that i mentioned
earlier still goes through and we still
get uh we are guaranteed that the
hypothesis that the output will have
with very high probability
generalization error at most epsilon
okay so in this case the total amount of
communication in terms of examples
communicated is d over epsilon times
logan over epsilon and we can also get a
similar result in the agnostic case in
that case would have to send d over
epsilon squared times logan of epsilon
examples and in both cases that would be
one round of communication
okay so this is the first baseline now
let me mention another simple baseline
for those of you familiar with uh
learning theory and mistake bound so it
turns out you can also have a baseline
based on a mistake bound guarantee so if
you are looking at a concept class e
that has a mistake bound of m
we can
uh basically have one of the players say
play around one run the mistake bound
algorithm so again we're gonna proceed
in round uh in each round player one
broadcast its current hypothesis if
everyone if there is any player that has
a counter example then uh that counter
example is sent to player one player one
user to update his current hypothesis
otherwise we are we stop if there is no
counter example
and it's immediate to see that uh based
on the mistake bang guarantees the the
the total amount of communication he
deciding which is in terms of the number
of examples communicated and also the
number of hypotheses communicated is m
whereas the mistake bound of the concept
class
okay and in fact if we also if we we can
have each player run a shadow algorithm
of the mistake bound algorithm and then
uh
we would only have to communicate
examples
okay
so basically uh as opposed to this the
previous baseline that i mentioned uh
here uh
there is no dependence in the in the
communication there is no dependence on
over epsilon but the number of rounds of
communication can be as large as m where
m is a mistake bound of our concept
class
okay so basically just to summarize the
baselines uh
on one hand the the first base line has
a linear dependence in d the vc
dimension of the concept class and one
over epsilon
uh uh and one over epsilon while the
second base line has no dependence on
one over epsilon but uh depends can
depend linearly in the mistake bound of
the concept class
okay so these are the baselines the the
interest in fact the cool fact is that
it turns out that you can do much better
so in particular we can do exponentially
better in one over epsilon than the
first base line so it turns out that we
can learn any concept class c of final
bc dimension d
by using only d log one over epsilon
examples of communication
okay so
and actually we can achieve this by
using uh
a distributed boosting uh implementation
and if an uh communication efficient
implementation of boosting uh in
particular of adaboost i'm going to
describe it for boost
okay
and since this is a bit of a again a
broader audience let me just mention
that boosting is an algorithmic famous
algorithmic technique for turning a weak
learning algorithm into a strong
learning algorithm and one popular
algorithm is the adaboost algorithm
so this algorithm text is input a
training set
of labeled examples and a weak learning
algorithm
and then it outputs
an algorithm that
help puts a hypothesis that achieves
arbitrarily small
error rates
okay and the algorithm proceeds in
rounds
in
round t we construct a distribution dt
over the training set
we've around the weak hypothesis
algorithm of this distribution dt to get
a new hypothesis ht and then we use that
hypothesis ht to reweight the examples
for the next round
and in particular what adaboost does
uh
so uh the way so okay so in the first
round first of all is the uniform
distribution over the examples i mean
it's just the first round and then
around t
uh we create a new distribution for dt
plus one for the next round by uh simply
increasing the weight on the examples on
which our hypo current hypothesis hd was
incorrect so increase the weight on the
hard example and then we decrease the
weight on
which
on the examples on which the current
hypothesis hd was correct so we decrease
the weight on the easy examples
okay so we saw adaboos does
uh now the specific formula is written
here the details are not important
what is important is and this is a key
point one of the key points that allows
us to implement boosting in a
distributed manner so the key point one
of the key points is that
at any moment in time the current weight
um
that algorith but other boosters in a
given example x i depends entirely
on the performance of the weak
hypothesis generality so far so depends
entirely on h 1 of x i h 2 of x i hd of
x i
right so depends entirely on the
performance of this hypothesis on our
example x i and also some normalization
factor that can be communicated
efficiently
okay so this is a key point
and another key point is that in order
to achieve weak learning uh order of the
examples uh are sufficient so to achieve
weak learning with respect to the
distribution dt and hrmt order the
examples are sufficient
okay so given this here is our
distributed boosting implementation so
we proceed in round
at the beginning of each round each
player
each player i sends to player one just
enough example so that player one can
produce a weak hypothesis
so for instance in the first round each
person only d over k examples
when uh player one does the computation
he computes a weak hypothesis over the
current distribution dt
and then
player one broadcasts the current
hypothesis ht to all the players and
then the players do the re-weighting of
the distribution locally so they use
their own examples by using the hyposis
hd
and then they also send they also
compute the total weight their current
total weight on their own examples
and when they send the total weight to
player 1 now player 1 aggregates these
total weights in order to determine how
many examples to ask from each player
for the next round
and in particular he'll gonna sample
order of the examples from the
multinomial given by
these weights essentially
okay so that's basically the distributed
implementation of boosting
and basically it turns out that
this
natural implementation leads to the
following results we can learn any
concept class e finite vc dimension d
by only using a logon over epsilon
rounds of communication and in each
round you only need to communicate order
of the examples
okay
that means great
okay and so
uh
and this basically follows so this fact
follows from the fact that
uh
basically in adaboost to achieve error
at most epsilon we only need logan over
epsilon round of communication
uh here is a weak learning whose edge
over the random guessing is a constant
so typical the number of rounds if every
week a gamma equilibrium will be one of
the gamma square logan over epsilon here
gamma is a constant
so basically only log one over epsilon
rounds of communication together or
almost epsilon
and furthermore in each round we really
communicate order of the examples
so
um
and some other low order bits like some
other order terms like
we also have to communicate by how much
our weight went up and down we also have
to communicate how many examples to send
from each player but in any case all
those are low order
terms so the dominant factor is
order of the examples per round logan
over epsilon rounds
okay and this gives us
uh
the desired result that we can learn any
concept classy or finance dimension d by
only using the logon of epsilon examples
of communication
okay and furthermore in the cases where
we have for the centralized setting
right we have an efficient algorithm for
getting a weak learning by only using
order of the examples
in both cases we also get a
computationally efficient procedure
okay
all right so this this result holds only
for
noisy settings for the realizable case
for the case of the target function
itself really belongs to my concept
class
okay it's very natural to ask also what
happens when you have noise
and it actually turns out to have a
generic result
for diagnostic case so for arbitrary
forms and noise now this result is not
computationally efficient anymore so
like the computation the amount of
computation done could be very high
but what's interesting about it is that
again for if we have a class c now in
this case if the class e is finite we
can again show that we can get a
communication efficient protocol whose
um
whose dependence on over epsilon is
exponentially better compared to the
baselines
so basically you can get a communication
efficient protocol whose uh
communication it looks like log size of
silicon over epsilon and this is again
exponential improvement over the the
baseline of the over epsilon squared
loganovan examples
okay and i'm not going to go into the
details here i'm happy to talk about
this offline just the high level beat
which i think is interesting is that we
we got this
this result for the noise for the noisy
cases by actually using
result that i had in a very different
context in the context of interactive
learning with general queries
and so it turned out that algorithm for
interactive learning with general
queries in particular with mistake
queries or class conditional queries was
crucial to achieving this result uh in
the distributed settings
okay and this points out and i think
alek mentioned this in his talk
yesterday right so this actually also
points out that there is i think there
is a very interesting high level
connection between active learning and
distributed learning so often naturally
algorithms that are
have a good sample complex in an active
learning scenario are turned out to be
useful primitives for getting uh
distributed learning algorithms with
good uh with small communication
complexity
okay so i think this is interesting and
again i'm happy to talk about the
details of line
obvious result
okay so so far i have talked mainly
about uh generic results so in the last
five minutes of the talk i also want to
mention that um
for uh specific cases
like for specific concept classes we can
do even better in terms of the number of
bits of communication in particular we
could potentially remove the dependence
on another epsilon or we could learn
fewer than the examples of communication
okay
and uh
a simple concept class a simple case
here is for the the class of
uh for for any intersection closed
concept class
uh which means so a concept class is
intersection closed if it has a property
that if we have hypothesis h in the
class and we have hypothesis aj in the
class then the intersection is also in
the class
so it turns out for but for any such
class
if we furthermore uh have the property
that each target function can be
described compactly like for instance
this is the case for the class of
conjunctions
uh which is intersection clause of the
class of intervals in the real lines
again intersection closed
so if the each function can also be
described compactly
then it turns out to improve over the
baseline methods okay
and here
here in particular the result we show is
that if c
the concept class is an intersection
clause concept class when the class c
can be learned
with uh only one round of communication
and k hypotheses of total communication
okay and
the algorithm is actually not very
complicated in this case
so very quickly what we do
so each ntti draws a sample as psi of
size d over epsilon logan over epsilon
and then it finds the smallest
hypothesis h i uh that is consistent
with its own sample and then sends that
to player one and when player one uh
outputs the smallest hypothesis h that
contains each hypothesis hi
okay and then uh the point is that
um
that h i so but basically that each
hypothesis is hi
never makes a mistake uh on on negative
examples because it's contained the
target function and so h never makes a
mistake and on positives you cannot this
yeah and on positives
the hypothesis h does only better
okay so this is a cute result where we
can
write or we can do much better uh than
the generic results and in particular
just to give a quick uh so for instance
a quick example for the class of
conjunctions which is intersection
closed so what the previous algorithm
reduces to is that each each player
first
finds the end the b twice and its own
examples
and sends that to player one
and then player one just again does does
a bit wise end of its own examples uh
all those of those k uh of verse k uh
uh examples that have been transmitted
to him
okay so in this case basically the
amount of communication is order of k
examples
each example takes order of d bits to
communicate and totally get k times the
bits of communication
which
can be much better than what we get by
generic methods because in this case the
generic methods require
order of the examples of communication
which
end up being d squared so when k
is
the number of players is much more than
d then we get
a
an improvement about the genetic methods
okay
and let me just mention and i'm not
going to go into
too many details i'm just going to
mention also that an interesting class
from communication point of view is a
class of parity functions so this is a
boolean class of functions the class of
parity functions
uh say over the d-dimensional boolean
cube now it turns out that in this case
the generic methods require order of the
examples of communication
so which means order of these square
bits of communication
and actually in fact if we use classic
communication complexity lower bounds
we show that this is needed so order of
this is needed if our goal is to output
to do proper learning so if our goal is
to up with a parity function
then order of omega of the squared
examples of communication are needed
and this is true even for k equals two
okay now what we show it's kind of i
think it's kind of cool in our work we
show that actually we can if we are
happy to do improper learning so that
means a hypothesis function is a more
complicated hypothesis function then we
can learn with only order of d bits of
communication
so i think which i think is kind of cool
okay
and uh
uh do i have time to go for the
procedure
two minutes left okay
so okay the very high level again uh uh
basically the this result follows from
the fact from the observation that
basically we can learn the class the
class of parity functions in two ways we
can learn it we can pack learn it
properly pack learn it all we have to do
is just
given a data set s of large enough size
just solve a linear system so you can
properly pack learn it but moreover we
can also non-properly pack learn it in
the reliable useful model which means
that
if we predict we can either pre
predict or say i don't know when we
predict we'll be totally correct
and moreover is the add-on and most an
epsilon fraction of the examples
right so uh and we can learn the parity
functions in this model in this reliable
useful model by simply just again draw a
large enough set of examples
and the prediction function is if the
examples if the new example the test
example is in the span of the examples
i've seen in the training seven i know
how to predict because these are
priority functions otherwise i say i
don't know
okay and basically using this fact the
the distributed boosting so the
distributed procedure is as follows uh
each player i basically uh pack length
of a return distribution so properly
packed length of return distribution to
get a parity function hi
it also learns in the reliable useful
model to get a rule gi and then it's and
then he sends his his parity function hi
that he learned in a proper way to the
other player and when player each player
then in order to predict on a new test
examples the way they predict is
if their reliable useful
hypothesis predicts this that doesn't
say i don't know if it predicts on that
example the user to predict otherwise
they predict using the other player's
hypothesis aj
okay and the key point is that
we're going to have loader under the
distribution dj for the other player
because
hj has distribution is lower on the dj
and moreover since gi never makes a
mistake putting it in front it doesn't
help it doesn't hurt
okay so that's basically a very quick
uh fast argument why this works that's
over the same trick and hold uh holds
for any class that is uh that can be
both
properly packed learned and learning the
reliability model
okay and this trick only works for k
equals two and we have two players and
it's an open question to do it in
general
okay cool so now to summarize to go back
at the higher level so basically in this
work we analyze communication complexity
as a
important fundamental resource when
doing distributed learning so i think
it's as important as sample complexity
and computational complexity
and we provide general bounds and the
amount of communication needed to learn
any concept class so bc dimension b and
in specific cases we
do even better we achieve even better
communication by using properties of the
specific cases
and there are obviously many interesting
open questions
in this area so i'm just going to
mention three of them so
the first one is basically for
noise-free settings we have efficient
algorithms but for the case where we
have noise say
any type of noise actually we don't have
efficient algorithms so achieving
efficient algorithms communication
complexity right uh polynomial
algorithms with good communication
complexity that's still an open question
obviously another natural question is
doing the same thing for other learning
tasks like clustering this has been
mentioned a lot in the workshop
and another question is so in my in our
model we assume that we are happy we are
pulling uh with communication protocols
that have the property but for each
player they use a polynomial time
algorithm and a polynomial sample and
then we wanted to minimize communication
but very naturally we could try to trade
off all these
three different types of resources
sample complexity communication
complexity and running time
okay
cool
thank you
question